فشلت رابطه المحترفين الانجليزيه بانها
تمرر قرار يخص منع التعاقدات او منع
استقدام اللاعبين على سبيل الاعاره بين
ناديين واحد منهم الدوري الانجليزي وواحد
قد يكون في اي دوري اخر ولكن لنفس المالك
او لنفس الجهه المالكه وبالتالي مثلا مثلا
على سبيل المثال مانشستر سيتي لا يستطيع
انه يستعير لاعب من جيرون ونيوكاسل ما
بستطيع انه يستعير لاعب من السعوديه هذا
القرار طبعا مثل ما حكينا فشل واليوم راح
نحكي عن فوائد فشل هذا القرار على نادي
نيوكاسل يونايتد في حلقه جديده من بعد
الصافره معي انا عبيده
[موسيقى]
نفاع نيوكاسل بالوقت اللي كل الناس عم
تحكي فيه عن موضوع انه قادر يتعاقد مع
لاعبين كبار بالدوري السعودي مره بيحكوا
عن نيفس مره بيحكوا عن بروزوفيتش مره
بيحكوا عن لاعبين اخرين ولكن دائما كان
الحديث عن المحترفين الاجانب طيب نيوكاسل
اذا بده محترفين اجانب ما هو بيجيب من
اوروبا يعني كان اساسا تعاقد مع هؤلاء
اللاعبين ما هو بروزوفيتش كان بانتر ميلان
ونيفس كان ب وولفز فكان ممكن انه نيوكاسل
يشتري هؤلاء اللاعبين او يجيبهم على سبيل
اعاره وما الى ذلك ولكن هذا الامر ما تم
واللاعبين اختاروا انه يروحوا على
السعوديه طيب بما انه هذا الموضوع فشل او
قصه انه منع الانديه من انها تتعاقد مع
لاعبين من من نادي اخر لنفس المالك فشل
ليش النيو كاسل او ليش الجماهير السعوديه
او المحلين السعوديين ما بفكروا بانه ليش
ما نطلع لعيبه سعوديين على نيوكاسل ليش ما
نيوكاسل يفكر بانه يستعير لاعبين سعوديين
مش اجانب من عننا ولا تقنعني انه مستوى
اللاعبين السعوديين او العرب عامه او
بالمنطقه اقل بكثير من اللاعبين الموجودين
بالدوري الانجليزي لانه هذا الكلام غير
صحيح نعم لاعبين الموجودين اليوم بنيوكاسل
او باي نادي اخر بانجلترا واصلين لمراحل
متقدمه بكره القدم لان انهم احتكوا بال
باللاعبين الكبار احتكوا بالمدربين الكبار
تدربوا صح اشتغلوا على حالهم صح لسنوات
طويله ولكن
كموهبة لنادي الهلال الظهير الايمن
للمنتخب السعودي برايي الشخصي سعود عنده
بوتنشال عالي جدا انه يكون واحد من افضل
لاعبي العالم لا بل انه كان في احاديث
ايام كاس العالم عن رغبه بعض الانديه
الاوروبيه بالتعاقد معه وبرايي الشخصي
سعود اذا بروح على نادي كبير بيكون في
مدرب يعني قادر انه يطور موهبته ويطور
اداؤه ويثقل اللي عنده ممكن يقدم مستويات
خرافيه لانه قدراته البدنيه وقدراته
المهاريه عاليه جدا وليش لا ما يكون بديل
ل تريبير بنيو نيو كاسل وممكن لاحقا ياخذ
مكانه فسع عبد الحميد بشوفوا خيار جيد
لانه نيوكاسل ايضا ما عندهم بديل جيد على
الجهه اليمنى ل تريبير اللاعب الاخر اللي
ممكن نفكر فيه هو عبد الرحمن غريب من نادي
النصر عبد الرحمن غريب لاعب مهاري لاعب مش
بس مهاري وسريع والى اخره لا هو لاعب عنده
شخصيه ايضا لانه شفناه بالمباريات اللي
لعبوها النصر المباريات الوديه التحضيريه
اللي كانت قبل بدايه الموسم امام بي اس جي
امام انتر قدم مستويات جيده عبد الرحمن
غريب عبد الرحمن غريب لاعب موهوب جدا وانا
شخصيا بزعل كثير لما بشوفه على دكه
البدلاء مع النصر بسبب وجود ساديو مانيه
او بسبب وجود لاعب اخر ولكن برايي غريب
ايضا اذا بينشغل عليه صح وبتطور
نقاط القوه عنده وبتحسن نقاط الضعف ممكن
يكون واحد من افضل اللاعبين ونيوكاسل ايضا
بيحتاجه لانه على الجهه اليسرى كمان على
الاجنحه نيوكاسل دائما بيحتاج لاعبين جداد
وبيحتاج تجديد كل فتره وفتره اللاعب الاخر
اللي كمان ممكن نحكي عنه هو مداف دافع
الهلال مدافع الاتحاد سابقا الهلال حاليا
حسان تمبكتي حسان تمبكتي اثبت نفسه بشكل
كبير بكاس العالم الاخير وخلال هذا الموسم
ايضا قدم مستويات جيده الموسم الماضي مع
الاتحاد كان رائع ايضا وبالتالي حسان عنده
قدرات ممتازه جدا وقد يكون افضل مدافع في
الدوري السعودي حاليا وربما في المنطقه
العربيه عموما حسان تمبكتي برايي بكل قوه
ممكن يكون موجود كبديل لفاب ان شار اللي
صار كبير بال امر كبديل لدان بيرن بحال
انصاب كبديل لسفين بوتمان كثير الاصابات
وبالتالي قد يكون خيار جيد بالنسبه
لنيوكاسل انه ممكن يفكروا فيه لذلك حسان
تمبكتي سعود عبد الحميد وعبد الرحمن غريب
هي اسماء كلها قادره انها تكون موجوده
بالدوري الانجليزي وبدوري الكبرى وفي
اسماء كبيره طبعا اخرى وكثيره بالدوري
السعودي لا يسعى المجال لذكرها ولكن عم
نشوف مع من شيني حاليا بالمنتخب السعودي
انه في ايضا مواهب صغيره بالسعوديه في
لاعبين الشباب عم يقدموا مستويات جيده
بتصفيات كاس العالم شفناهم فازوا على
الاردن شفناهم فازوا ايضا قبليها على
باكستان وعم بيعطي فرص منشين لمهاجمين جدد
للاعبين جدد في منتصف الملعب للاعبين جدد
بالدفاع وبالتالي عم نسمع اسماء جديده
بالمنتخب السعودي ما كنا نسمعها بكاس
العالم
2022 ف برايي الشخصي الطموح الان او
المشروع بالنسبه للسعوديه اكيد هو تطوير
الكره السعوديه مهم جدا داخليا ولكن
بالنسبه للجمهور السعودي بالنسبه لتدعيم
المنتخب ايضا المنتخب بحاجه للاعبين
محترفين برا اكثر قادرين انه يحتكوا اكثر
مع الانديه الكبيره مع الفرق الكبيره
يطوروا العقليه يطوروا نظام الاكل يطوروا
نظام التدريب ويتعلموا تكتيكات كره القدم
ويفهموا كره القدم من منظور مختلف عن اللي
حاليا عم يتعلموه او اللي عم يشتغلوا عليه
داخل السعوديه مع الاحترام الكبير
للمدربين الموجودين بالسعوديه ولكن
بالتاكيد لحد الان لا يقارنوا بالمدربين
الموجودين باوروبا لذلك اعتقد انه هذا
لازم يكون المشروع والتفكير على مدار
الفتره المقبله خلينا نشوف شو راح يصير هل
نيوكاسل راح يتعاقد فعلا مع لاعبين من
الدوري السعودي هل راح يختار لاعبين
سعوديين هذا امر متروك للمستقبل ولكن رايي
الشخصي الاساس هو اللاعب السعودي والاساس
هو اللاعب العربي واللاعب ابن البلد قبل
كل شيء وقبل
التفكير هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه اليوم بعد
الصافره حتى نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل كونوا
بالف
خير
ه